today's question is a little indulgent
because it's about me so this is a
question that's come up lots in live
streams face-to-face interactions at
conventions and in other places so I
think this will be a good chance to you
know really give it a place to sit the
original idea for foldy came from two
main incentives first being the need for
some sort of visual hook to make my work
stand out from others as I was initially
promoting it on forums and in other
places
the second incentive was delivery with
the original memes pilot I was not
terribly satisfied with my delivery
particularly the fact that you could
tell like it was really obvious that I
was reading the script off the laptop
screen using the puppet would solve that
problem by allowing me to read the
script directly you know it's not the
only solution to that problem but the
two elements dovetailed nicely so Foley
was always intended to be a surrogate of
myself rather than a distinct character
or persona and that brings us to the
second part of the question if I also
appear in the videos then are we
diabetic ly separate or what and to that
I say yes and no in that regard whenever
I Foley utter plushie whenever any of us
are on screen it's always me the
conversations that we have which are all
written by me are conversations that I
am having with myself ideas life the
world it's a complicated place and it's
possible for there to be a lot of
different sides to an issue a lot of
different incentives or motivations or
goals and these things don't always line
up neatly I debate with myself all the
time I like things for a lot of
different reasons and I dislike things
for just as many reasons why do I defend
Chronicles of Riddick an objectively
terrible movie while keeping a program
on Jurassic world by having two or more
versions of myself that I can put on
screen it allows me to present
conflicting arguments while still having
the content of those arguments be
authentically my own voice so thank you
for your question as always you've got
questions for the mailbag the best place
to submit them is through ask fm and
also there's that whole Twitter thing
now go in peace my children in the name
of like share and subscribe amen